السنه الدراسه الباحثين التي نشرت في مجله
نيتشر الى اكتشاف اثري نادر ورشه تحنيط مع
مجموعه من الفخار يزيد عمرها على 2500 عام
في مقابر شهيره في سقاره العديد من الجرار
لا تزال موجود في الموقع مكتوبه بتعليمات
مثل ان يغتسل او يوضع على راسه
انه امر رائع ايضا اننا تمكنا من العثور
على مواد غريبه جدا
ومنتجات قادمه من الغابات المطيره وعلى
الارجح من اسيا
كشف عن الورشه عام 2016 من قبل مؤلف
الدراسه رمضان حسين وبعد ذلك بعامين تحدث
عن الاكتشاف وقدرته على كشف اسرار التحنيط
وهذا
لدينا مخبا للتحنيط يعود تاريخه الى
القرنين السابع والخامس قبل الميلاد هذا
المخبئ مهم جدا لانه واسع جدا في الجانب
الذي لدينا فيه اكواب قياس من الزيوت
والمواد التي استخدمت في التحنيط لذلك نحن
امام منجم ذهب للمعلومات
من خلال مطابقه الكتاب على السطح الخارجي
للاوعيه مع الاثار الكيميائيه بداخلها كشف
الباحثون عن تفاصيل جديده حول الوصفات
التي ساعدت في الحفاظ على المومياوات
لالاف السنين بحيث ان التحنيط كان يدور
حول تحويل الانسان الى كيان مقدس والهي
يمكنه ان يعيش الى الابد وفقا لعلماء
الاثار في الماضي حصل الخبراء على بعض
القرائن حول بعض المواد ومنها راتنج زيت
ايليني من خلال اختبار المومياوات الفرديه
والنظر في النصوص المصريه المكتوبه لكن
ظلت هناك الكثير من الثغرات وفقا للمؤلفين
وسعرت الاكتشافات الجديده على حلها